you
hi everyone is Gerry there's a fun game
from season 9 of the ongoing top chess
engine championship that I'd like to
share with you I think you'll enjoy this
this is the game between the engine now
I'm plying on the white end and Houdini
just to give you some insight here this
is a rapid time control game 25 minutes
with a 10-second increment and as far as
the strength of each engine now is just
above 3000 rating and Houdini is nearly
3200 so let's see what it is about this
game exactly that has me titling it
Houdini's pawn storm starts quite enough
d4 d5 Knight f3 e6 and Bishop f4 the
calm before the storm c5 Knight c3 see
many computers make a move like this
where the C pawn is obstructed usually
something to steer clear of in Queen
pawn like games C pawn likes to
contribute but in this game it will not
light up 6 this is not a threat Knight B
5 can be met with Queen a5 and the
knight must return however after e3 this
is something and that idea is killed
altogether a 6
I've played games before in similar
situations where I just develop and say
well I could meet this move with Knight
a6 and I'm defending the threat that is
true but what's also true is you're not
getting rid of this Knight so easily
this is a bother to black you can't play
a6 can't get rid of that night so easily
so this move should be shut down and it
is a 6 on board Bishop e2 d5 putting to
use a 6 it's not developing but is
grabbing some Queen side space maybe
trying to give the knight a time
kick
that stopped about a three secures the
night v4 would not be a good idea
because the a file would open up and the
very thing you wanted you're a pawn to
do control b5 he isn't doing anymore
because of this pin big trouble for
black so v4 is no good some natural
stuff coming in though
Bishop b7 White's King is now castled
Knight B to d7 white improves the night
this file can open up at any moment
Knight takes Knight and the first move
of this game that caught my attention
Knight takes Knight
why not do this recapture and develop
you could do that but let's see what the
idea behind Knight takes Knight is
exactly Queen d3 with this last move
White has connected rooks black on the
other hand still needs three more moves
Bishop move castles Queen move before
there's a connection between the rooks
few moves back like it's one of them in
they should be seven natural enough
Bishop f3 improving the bishop possibly
preparing a pawn break ideally this is
what White would like to do here have
the position open up create pawn
captures and put to use hopefully this
lead in development but now comes one of
the most committal or I could probably
say it the most committal move in chess
g5 at least on the black end yeah
castling over here not a good choice
three holes are now present so blacks
basically going all-in with the move
like g5 bishops hit Bishop g3 black is
not finished
h5 threatening to trap the bishop
there's now a new square available f5
yeah all eight pawns are rolling Bishop
e2 g4 rook F to d1 King f7 let's just
stop for a moment what to say here this
is a don't try this at home
tie position ah a lot of principles have
been violated here let's say 16 moves in
9 pawn advances and you're making a king
move you're not castling just making a
King move okay black is
with this last move step closer to
connecting rooks but wants to keep the
rook here controlling the h-file Lex
looking to attack the white king
grabbing a ton of space now how is it
that black can get away with maybe doing
something like this well there isn't a
great way to have this position open up
there isn't a great way to gain access
to let's say the black King position you
know there's a lot of pawns that have
moved forward but where is that key pawn
break I mean when that f5 move was
played there's now a pretty strong lock
down on any e4 break sure there can be a
capture here but is this really
benefiting team white you know the
knight can he not be the one to
recapture and improve and maybe I up e4
not a great way to get at the black King
not a great way to exploit these
violations several pawn moves nine pawn
moves of the first 16 moves and a king
move like this let's see how play
follows Queen d2
row g8 H takes H takes we now have a
completely opened H file rook F one
serious space disadvantage here for
white yeah these pawns are a bit much
Knight f6 going to e1 let's see how
white tries to defend Bishop to d6 this
is one of the last well really the only
defender of whites King so blacks trying
to eliminate that Bishop d6 white hangs
on to the bishop now the rook gets right
back over to the open file f4 the queen
is there we saw the idea now behind
Queen to e1 but this is already gone for
team white
rook h5 preparing to double up triple up
whatever it takes this is the inroads
into White's position the h-file so rook
a to d1 well that's the only work that
could go there Queen h8 g3 this right
now is the glue Bishop on h4 without
this Bishop around well if the bishop
isn't around you get in here
h1 h2 squares so let's see how black
gets rid of that Bishop first
inconvenience is the knight pushing
forward yet again with upon that Knight
is rocked back Bishop to e7 uh-huh
preparing to challenge that Bishop also
improve the knight this is game over for
team white C files now opened up all
pieces are playing for black this Bishop
any moment the pawn can move the rook is
here the Knights now doing what hopping
into the center every piece doing
something yeah Bishop d3 there goes the
bishop what more is there to do if you
take here you're getting mated instead
of a bishop move Bishop takes Bishop and
got a mate and three happening so can't
even move the bishop
Bishop takes pawn takes rook takes rook
h3 if Rick takes rook we're recapturing
it the Queen and that's going to be a
disaster main six is calling for already
Bishop takes Knight
F takes and there's nothing here there
hasn't been anything here for White
Queen age five preparing to now triple
up ID to rook h8 Queen G 1 G 3
supporting rook H 2 now maybe even Queen
f3 and some lines and just playing it
out a few more moves after D 4 on takes
enters the bishop with an e 3 move in
the game though the move this is the
last move of the game f5 and it goes no
further
at this point light throws in the towel
this is the end of the game there's it's
already calling for a mate in 8th time
to just show one of the lines let's go
with this one suppose pawn takes pawn on
takes King eh Queen takes rook takes
rook rook takes rook and this King gets
locked all the way down pretty much and
what more is there King here Queen h5
and then rook to g6
but this is as far as it goes after f5
it's already enough the charts calling
for mate at this point but interesting
game one that I could actually you know
computer games are quite often pretty
difficult to wrap your head around
difficult difficult to understand but
this one it's instructive seeing the C
pawn not be a contributor could violate
certain opening principles here making
multiple pawn moves every pawn is
advancing in this one but how can you
get away with this how can you what what
allows stuff like this to happen in the
game well the position cannot be cracked
open so easily black can go on Castle
black can make nine pawn advances in
this specific case black has control
over the keep on breaks and there wasn't
a good way for why
to put to use that lead in development
in this tremendous space advantage this
tremendous pond storm was really
interesting to see just crashing through
here on the h-file broken right down so
cool game definitely has a nice little
look to it a statically pleasing game
seeing all those pawns advance so early
on anyhow
feel free to share any feedback to this
game or this video in the comment
section below and I hope you enjoyed it
that's all for now take care bye
you